[Music]
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters
those 10 seconds or less
the open road could take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Toretto
the law for adventure let's do it to see
something new when he mayn't riff just
to come back home again we go the
fastener Firoz saga has explored the
endless possibilities of the open road
from the streets just outside downtown
Los Angeles we've taken you to Miami
we've taken you to Tokyo
Republic Rio London Abu Dhabi and now
our name is known all over the world
one nice ride
we have raced for speed race for honor
queued on was had you greens or cities
tumbled down mountains and even dropped
out of the sky but no matter how our
adventures grow fast and furious is
always about one very important thing
Pam the most important thing in life
will always be the people in this room
salute me Familia our family of
characters do everything for each other
and with each other for the millions who
make up our global family advance we
push ourselves to go further and do
better time after time
we never ride alone we never ride alone
this time it ain't just about being fast
now we embark on our next chapter our
family will be challenged like never
before by adversaries who show no mercy
testing that bomb that has always kept
us together
dishes most entertaining fastest and
most furious Raja
this is fast and furious
was very meaningful plane Hanuman wrote
it and then sent it down to New Zealand
so it was blessed by our elders my
biggest role here was making sure that